we go [__] a Sunday night we're
going deep tonight in this [__]
you guys thought we were [__] around
ain't nobody smoking week to that we'll
[__] going deep with hash under a
glass see your [__] don't know
nothing about this we're gonna go deep
tonight into the murky waters on the
[__] I'm the world look at that smoke
we go boys right there come on we say
yeah that's quality one that's right
this is
get brother these guys will pay it's
coming out from the bottom already walk
yeah like this is like [__] Grandpa's
on the monster type [__]
check it out [__] can't be
wasting they like you bad [__]
on a Sunday night how the [__] you think
you're dealing with it look at that
going deep
greetings from the [__] one i jus
[__] you're gonna turn me into the one
I do
they suck the rest of them look spinning
our wish how to so living in a fishbowl
like a doctor [__] what have
you done for your country lately [__]
nothing badmouth your country listen to
Mick Jagger music and [__] smoke coming
out from the bottom of that [__]
you see that smoke right there
[__] you think you're dealing with baby
boy huh Sunday March 6th at Churchill
what's happening now pre-show taking you
deep with some good hash I'm under a
glass listened to Pink Floyd wish you
were here
don't forget much better than this [__]
[__] wait think one more [__]
hit are you [__] kidding me or what
this is some enchanted evening leave one
more for the [__] Nazis let's do it
one more for [__] you bad [__]
look at you trim it up doing kettlebells
not bad it's [__] sweaty that's
what's supposed to happen
you're supposed to get all head sweaty
what am I doing this guy's you know no
one knows what up ash under a glass is
[__] North Bergen the shedder villo
old-school you could see your moisture
from the [__] I see that I'm coming
you got a piece of hash get one of your
pins in your sister's room
put it right on that here's the way to
go on a Sunday night don't get me wrong
we got edibles we got three full of rube
we got everything we got some [__]
residential like a mother fire can't see
without my glasses look at his bone of
debt we have them
oh [__] Lisa how you feeling baby boy
it's bedtime is Sunday night time to
reflect get your notebook just sit tight
after 60 minutes I think vinyl comes on
at 8:40
now we'll do a joint hash combo this
really goes down deep dislike dude or
safe to say that of THC my heart attack
at 9:15
you guys want to [__] around and you
want to keep [__] around with these
Momo's who'll get tattoos a weed 420 in
the head post this bump those
[__] no post is no nothing
straight-up gangster reefer in this
[__]
with smoking reefer like we only treat
eagerly
look at this [__] cloud of smoke
that's developed right by the hash ball
right there
BAM where do you get this type
entertainment huh
nowhere that's why you're here with
uncle Joey tonight it's a beautiful
night to be alive what the [__] is going
on him
hey go look at me looking handsome as
[__] haha take one more hit of the hash
and you're a soldier in heat look at you
it's getting more dope this your
training [__] you were training
I smoked crack for six weeks it was like
a training camp
it's doing
if you're gonna go deep you gotta go
deep with the [__] Cuban and the Jew
that's the way we do it in if you wanna
[__] and [__] around and eat granola
bars and be gluten free I have another
no PC here no filter we plug from the
[__] heart either you're in or
you're out [__] the guess the
night
we passed my men judgment made junky
Colin let you guys know the events what
happened what didn't happen what's gonna
happen what's up dog
you want some more action alright listen
up lady bother me for your way elected
like a [__] fire
you're thinking why am i watching this
why not what yeah let's go watch the
dude lying to him I'm leaves I'm here
we're [__] family uncle Joey on the
Sun this is good as it gets in your
world luckiest day you had was the day
you got your hit the dog got hit by a
car and here we are chitchat smoking
Aretha listen the [__] floor you
gotta ask yourself who's better than me
not me you who's better than you nobody
most people are not jumping up and down
being fake telling each other lies here
we are like [__] blowing hash balls
and [__] the whole thing with my
little brother Lisa at
you see then I [__] baller-ass
disintegrated again props to the one I
drew you know we are and you know where
yet please relieve me of this [__]
present that you join little E's at war
[__] up sure you are
what the [__] you think you're dealing
with what do you want to do with your
life
it all starts tomorrow Monday come on
your second chance ITT text opens up at
nine o'clock
you could be there signing financial aid
paperwork by 9:15 the recruiter also
opens up at nine o'clock tomorrow
shine on you crazy [__] diamond
a little song they wrote for their
[__] leaders Syd Barrett
while they were doing this out Syd
Barrett walked into the [__] studio
huh what do you think of that but listen
to Gilmour just schooling [__]
yeah tremendous not better listen to
music with your homies just listen or
what the [__] this guy's saying now he's
putting it together
and sure
what do you want from me we'll sit in
the end finishing up this number then
we'll start the podcast like tip tip
guru and you're on for some people they
like wake up in the morning BAM
there's the podcast at 6 a.m. wave them
like [__] an envelope understand me
remember is consistency [__] stay
on top of [__]
it's painful I wish you were here my
brother it's just [__] legendary [__]
oh this gets Gary - really this is deep
this app will [__] your world up if you
hear everything with them as like a
heartbeat
so why connects with you why are you
trippin they always have a heartbeat
Pink Floyd so when you're sitting there
tripping on acid right and you're
feeling your heart also your heart mixes
with the music on baseline oh listen
so it's [__] Pink Floyd's a bad
[__]
they got five albums gonna put you into
a different planet oh my good luck I
think that's named within it Dark Side
of the Moon
wish you were here animals the war they
got my four or five our metal something
like that who the [__] knows denies I've
been smoking hash eatin edibles at the
family today with the jujitsu today you
know how we do it
I did kettlebells are [__] Thursday I
was sure Friday heavy little bit on 7th
11th you to a stretch doc before and
after come on I got the movies in the
morning with the family some kids movie
at 10:00 a.m. until she perfect [__]
new girl I get stoned to the gills and
we'll see some zoom movie with my
daughter and mom she lose her mind by
like 11:15 all that pop one's [__]
disgusted calories okay what the [__]
you talking about
I'm trying to lose [__] 20 pounds I
want to be a fat [__] that popcorn
for the movie theater go on MyFitnessPal
doctor and type in medium movie popcorn
it's 1,100 [__] calories with butter
forget about this [__] I bring an apple
some Raisinets and I throw up a beat
imagine on a movie dinner like an apple
that's the type of [__] half a [__]
I've become in my world 1,100 [__]
calories for this medium fat boy
I almost died I got a [__] roll over
with twenty five-year-olds to burn
calories
you're talking about don't give a [__]
about popcorn watch anyway
how cool is I don't give a [__] it's
well I don't need nothing you guys
[__] breakfast a protein shake you go
there watch the movie you go stone to
the [__] gills oh [__] we got 12
minutes to crack of this [__]
and that's it we just have a little tape
time saying we do this we can't play
music on the shirt so we do a pre and a
post show except last Wednesday we got
too [__] high in here last Tuesday
with that [__] voltage poor kids that
poor bastard
unbelievable
well you got a good people you try all
you can do is open up your heart and let
people know you love them and whatever
happens happens you understand me and
that's it we'll be back the church will
be on what's the [__] YouTube
youtube.com slash jude youtube.com slash
what oh [__]
youtube.com slash user slash math favors
world flash live who the [__] you think
you're dealing I can't remember that
even if I wanted to
what's up there Boris what Boris stole
to the gills on a Sunday night sure it's
actually a different kind of thought
I've been telling you since day one
ashes uh you can do hash by itself all
day and you see what you feel like you
feel different no no this the hash is
the bridge to the elements
my body didn't hang on once a head so I
could kick in the stomach and you won't
feel like I got a tissue what do you
think thank you sure he won't go through
the size of my [__] hook up my fish I
got a hook on my face he wasn't give me
one for one of these [__] things it's
like me wiping my hands on one of these
things your finger goes through next
thing you know you're passing out of the
toilet I pass out if I see [__] smell
[__] I wanna see nothing oh [__] we're
going deep tonight I broke out the
menthol for you [__] I almost
had a [__] seizure the other place
one song from the other side just to let
you know is crack look at this look at
this album cover
shine on you crazy diamond opens up this
side there's only four songs of this
house it goes on they say 16 minutes or
something these [__] are [__]
up covering [__] we'll get the sleeve
the sleeve on this out wish you were
here here it's got wish you were here
has shine on you crazy diamond welcome
to the machine
have a cigar wish you were here and
that's it
as for songs but you saw this [__] for
15 minutes because their side waters
shine on you crazy time and what we
could misty scene then it goes back to
shell on you crazy diamond this
craziness
these guys don't [__] around side to his
Abbas to God wish you were here and
shine on you crazy diamond part 2 this
is part 1 is how it opens up this is
just totally [__] brilliant
right here what drugs'll me out for this
day world a [__] h this is the only
thing you could [__] the only people
who could write [__] like this this
suddenly is doing that Chinese white
that's why those Chinese [__]
do the cubic root the Rubik cube and all
that [__] why do those Chinese
[__] know because they it's
that white powder month we've been
sparking [__] where the [__] you
been [__] we smoke some hash we smoked
some bonus debt I'm stoned to the
[__] gills look my eyes can't get no
[__] better
we listen to the first side I wish you
were here which is shine on you crazy
diamond like I was telling [__] leave
and this is like a mindfuck you go home
you put this on by mistake you tripping
on acid do you walk upon a mirror or
something like that and I said you hear
this guitar in the background on this
stuff this is too much then I'll make
music like this no more
you gotta lower the lights to get the
full effect on the breaking [__] this is
too much
watch this people watch this
are you [__] kidding me or what come
and direct to you [__] the
church [__] a little wish you
[__] here
I think it's 1978 don't [__] matter
they didn't make this 10 years ago this
will take you back me and listen you do
a half an ass you go home you turn the
lights down you put this [__] arm on
you roll a number
you brought you bust a notebook out you
get some water so you don't dehydrate
and it's [__] you're gonna write a
[__] the story of your life the same
that way these guys wrote this [__] and
[__] up although she is doing acid and
then having a piece of paper pencil [__]
whatever comes to you life very
generically yeah supposed to tell you
what's in the deepest quality of mine
what are you thinking about easily
this is too much
this is too much they can't do this
stuff musically just called you right
now it's the acid trip right now you're
trying to do something awesome here that
guitarist says partly here we go
there we go
fine LLL 11 and 11 I don't pamper
here we go kick it
no no no no no no
here we got [__] this is why
david gilmour on is one of my favorite
[__] you thought by the top three this
guy right here it was him in the singer
the bass player [__] yeah
if you ain't do nothing pull out wish
you idiot
but their phones on listen to what the
[__] were listening to smoke a joint go
to the garage real quick don't have one
get all of these really there's a guitar
it is an organ player so he fills the
gaps that's why it sounds like [__]
Johnny tornados not me but here we go
his Gilmour it just [__] kills it
bamm-bamm about my man
we'll watch [__] to watch the
2016 very mellow but their mind [__]
their mind father here right now they're
just mind [__] me there's something
in your at home tripping right now your
hearts beat and you're like as I'm safe
like I'm [__] safe but there's
something here
they're sucking eland like they always
do is a Pink Floyd he does baby Dona
gets deep or this suction and you wanna
jump out the [__] window but you
can't get the window open you live in in
anyway we're starting to church up five
minutes we'll be back I love you
[__] YouTube / suck my dick
slush mad flavors world / live 20 of
life no parole
I'll see you [__] over there
alright [__]
I love you guys stay blackish